[Music]
the country
has been turned upside down by the
pandemic i got on the airplane on march
27th
when i arrived in india the case load
was like 80
000 a day by the middle of may it had
climbed to 400
000 i mean just tragic beyond belief
i was watching it grow
[Music]
india first authorized the use of the
serum institute vaccine which is called
kova shield
and the bharat vaccine which is called
covaxin they started
vaccinating people january 16th so
they're about a month behind the united
states in terms
of rolling out vaccine christian medical
college in velour
which is an enormous campus of five
different hospitals when they rolled out
the vaccine
after six weeks time 30 percent of the
doctors and nurses hadn't been
vaccinated
we saw hesitancy like that in health
care systems in the united states
but not at that level and certainly not
at the most prominent
medical institutions
part of it i think is linked to the fact
that adults aren't used to being
vaccinated he doesn't want to take
vaccines
and why not
[Music]
he is not bothered about it because he
feels that
nothing will happen to him in the case
of mumbai i went through the slums
with a group of what are called barefoot
researchers they're
young people who grew up in the slums
and they worked for an ngo called phukar
that helps the slums improve living
conditions
and at the same time does research into
diarrheal diseases
you teach people about the mass yeah but
hardly anyone here wears masks
they don't believe lots of people don't
even say
viruses like sars kovi 2 love
slums it is the ideal condition for the
virus
close quarters unmasked you know whereas
many people who have
money can stay home and shelter in place
that's pretty hard when you don't
have any resources and you don't have
food so
you're forced to go to work and put
yourself at risk
getting on public transport but this
surge in india
make no mistake is hitting every sector
of society
the system broke down
[Music]
so
i think we're at the crisis moment now i
think we're going to pass through it
there will be more and more supply of
vaccine
available so you're coming for your
second vaccine
business as usual doesn't work the
vaccines work
we know they do they do allow us to open
up again
everywhere in the world should enjoy
this
return to normalcy everywhere can get
there
with enough product and enough
willingness
to take the vaccine and enough structure
of public health systems to get it
to people and to educate and make it
easy for them
to receive their vaccines if we don't
take care of everyone in the world as
many people have stressed
we're just asking for the virus to keep
coming back at us wherever we live